can creativity of the kind that you  exemplify can that be taught can it be  something passed on from a mentor to a  to a protege or is it something that  really is inborn innate insurance at the  middle schoolish age it's really fun for  me like explaining things to kids of  that age but they don't have any fear of  asking questions about all kinds of  things later on they're much more  uptight oh what are people going to  think if I asked this question I think  my working hypothesis would be that sort  of everybody has a quite good degree of  creativity it's a question of whether  they have the forcefulness perhaps  confidence or the things around them  develop enough of that that they can  bash through and apply them